hallo ihr lieben heutige zeuge die
antwort auf die typische frage was koche
ich heute wir kochen heute oder bereiten
heute ein totally nie gemüseauflauf zu
hamza freut sich schon mal eine super
lecker ich hab den ja letzte woche
zubereitet bei hansa zu hause bei seinen
eltern nicht da sind da ich mal so ein
bisschen gekocht und das war sofort
verputzt nichts mehr übrig nach fünf
minuten und jetzt zeige ich euch
zuallererst die zutaten
hier habe ich meine auflaufform gefüllt
mit tortellini die sind jetzt mit käse
gefüllt aus dem kühlregal ich zeige euch
gerne mal meine selbstgemachte variante
heute soll sogar schnell gehen außerdem
benötigen wir gemüse ich habe hier
paprika genommen
zwiebeln ich habe hier die rote
knoblauchzehe außerdem passierte tomaten
ein gemisch aus fett amma sahne und
milch
außerdem etwas mehl und sonnenblumenöl
an gewürzen salz pfeffer ihr süßes
paprikapulver oregano und etwas chili
das schaf chef marc und außerdem noch
paniermehl und käse für die kosten drauf
mein gemüse gebe ich jetzt direkt zu den
tortellini und ihr könnt ihr das gemüse
auch austauschen ich hatte letztens zum
beispiel mais erbsen das hatte ich noch
tiefkühl brokkoli tiefkühlgemüse geht
auch wunderbar und es gibt jetzt einfach
mit dazu dann zeige ich euch wie die
soße machen
[Musik]
als nächstes geht es auf dem herd weiter
ich damit zum einen topf erhitzt das öl
darin und dann werde ich darin zwiebeln
und knoblauch andünsten und zwar so
ungefähr für 12 minuten
[Musik]
den herd habe ich auf mittlere stufe
eingestellt und da bleibt ja jetzt auch
denn jetzt denen wir unsere mehr dazu
und desktop später für so eine richtig
schöne sämige konsistenz jetzt einfach
dazu geben und unterrühren einmal
richtig schön einarbeiten und ich ihm
dafür ist mein schnee beten
[Musik]
ca 20 minuten lang lassen wir das
militär in anschwitzen und dann löschen
wir das ganze auf entweder mit unseren
passierten tomaten oder mit dem sahne
milch gemischt es völlig egal hauptsache
gibt es langsam rein einem dünnen
strahlt und dann immer wieder schöne
rühren damit sich das auch schön
verbindet und sich keine klümpchen
bilden
[Musik]
habe ich grade 20 minuten gesagt man
hier natürlich 20 sekunden also minuten
sekunden ist meine sekunden nachdem die
passierten tomaten komplett
eingearbeitet wurden geben wir noch
milch und sahne gemischt mit rein
hier könnt ihr auch zum beispiel nur
milch oder nur seine nehmen das
vollkommen euch überlassen
[Musik]
soll die flüssigkeiten sind jetzt gut
eingearbeitet worden und jetzt für nur
noch unsere gewürze die gebe ich jetzt
in einem schwung mit drei früher das
unter an dann ist unsere so sei schon
fertig
[Musik]
die soße ist jetzt fertig ich habe
nochmal die gewürze richtig schön
eingerührt die so so muss nichts winkt
noch einmal aufkochen den ofen habe ich
schon vorgeheizt auf 200 grad ober
unterhitze und jetzt vereinen wir nur
kurz die zutaten miteinander und dann
geht's weiter
so die soße habe ich es mir zu den
tortellini es gegeben und habe die
richtig schön untergehoben und als
nächstes gehen wir nur noch käse und
paniermehl drauf und falls ihr euch
fragt was hat denn hier panel für
funktionen das macht die kruste noch mal
richtig schön knusprig ist also ein
kleiner geheimtipp von mir und noch mal
ganz gut sind heute ließ ich bin mir
sicher da kommt die frage bestimmt ihr
müsst sie nicht vor kochen ihr könnt sie
einfach froh da reingeben das gilt auch
für nudelsorten zum beispiel dann
verändert sich ein bisschen die garzeit
aber mit tortellini schmeckt der auflauf
einfach richtig schön besonders
[Musik]
ein käse habe ich jetzt auch dem auflauf
verteilt jetzt gebe ich noch ein
bisschen premium drauf und dann kommt
das ganze im backofen so lange bis der
käse goldbraun ist ich würde sagen 20
bis 25 minuten dann müsste einfach immer
mal wieder ein auge drauf haben
so ihr lieben wert heute linie
gemüseauflauf ist fertig und schmeckt er
unglaublich gut und ich kenne auch
niemanden der den nicht mag der ist
sofort verputzt verspreche ich euch ihr
könnt ihn gerne noch mit einem
gemischten salat servieren und dann
lasst ihr euch einfach schmecken
die genauen mengenangaben findet ihr
hier unten in der infobox und ihr könnt
auch wie gesagt einige zutaten
untereinander austauschen das schreibt
ihr euch auch nochmal unten genauestens
rein ansonsten freue ich mich wenn ihr
das rezept mal ausprobiert wie fotos mit
dem hashtag s kitchen auf instagram
sinne darüber freue ich mich immer total
ansonsten freue ich mich wenn ihr auch
beim nächsten mal wieder dabei sein
abonniert mich aktiviert gerne die
glocke dann bekommt ihr auch immer mit
wenn neues video anderen ist und ein
bisschen nach oben wir auch nicht
schlecht bis zum nächsten mal tschüss
[Musik]
leute ich habe relativ gut ist
die dieses gemachte für das schmeckt so
lecker kämpfen 100% klein groß mittel
alles auch halt mittel das mir kamanaka